[Music]
a hologram of ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky
cute dogs in the battlefield and
destroyed russian tanks put on public
display
ukraine has been able to galvanize
domestic and global support with
propaganda tailor-made to go viral it's
managing to make its case that it's the
underdog operating a defensive stance
against a
bullying aggressor here's what a 21st
century pr campaign looks like during a
war and how raising global awareness has
helped ukraine secure funds and weapons
to fight off russia's invasion
from the early days of war zelensky has
been busy addressing global leaders
becoming the face of the country's
resistance in the span of about three
months he virtually attended about 40
events
the end of this war and its
circumstances depend on the world's
attention he is the leader of his people
in a kind of david versus goliath
situation
paul baines has been monitoring keeve's
propaganda tactics throughout the
conflict he says getting ukraine's most
well-known figure in front of the
world's most influential people at high
profile events is an effective way to
keep the public interested he's well
aware that this is a long haul over time
when it's no longer newsworthy western
governments might forget about them his
communications are designed to ensure
that doesn't happen
one consistent message in many of
zielenski's speeches has been the call
for more weapons
and by mid-june the us has supplied more
than five billion dollars worth of
weapons to ukraine on top of other
military support from western allies
you're my hero zielenski has also been
tapping the power of celebrities
for example in early may he invited pop
rock band u2 frontman bono and guitarist
the edge to visit ukraine
they performed in a subway station
turned bunker with a soldier who fronts
one of ukraine's biggest pop rock bands
[Music]
these sorts of invites and meetings have
also coincided with zolensky's efforts
to raise financial aid the same week as
bono's visit the government launched a
website that would be the country's main
venue for donations raising more than
136 million dollars by early july
[Music]
one key part of ukraine's 21st century
propaganda toolkit is social media to
resonate with the younger generation
ukraine's official twitter account has
been covering the latest from the war
through art to boost morale of those
living in russian occupied cities as
well as hashtags and memes about weapons
ukraine's ministry of foreign affairs
has also posted content of animals in
the battlefield to soften the image of
the military
[Music]
one of its most popular mascots is
padron the demining dog that received a
military medal from zielenski it
appeared on the canadian prime
minister's twitter feed and the dog's
own tiktok account had nearly 3 million
likes by early july if it's got a dog or
a cat
it's much more likely to go viral but
leads to this cuteness of course is the
message that we're picking up these
weapons we have the ability to demine
our country and so it's another symbol
of resistance
zalenski's instagram has also been
featuring ads like this
it shows a montage of people at a gas
station
[Music]
the video goes on to say that eu
countries that continue to import
russian energy are funding moscow's war
efforts and killing ukrainians
this post was viewed more than 4 million
times since early april
it's one part of ukraine's ongoing
efforts to isolate russia economically
and in may less than two months after
that video was released the european
union pledged to ban 90 of russian oil
imports by year end
many of the videos released by ukraine
are heavily produced like this one using
color filters
they have an increasingly well developed
film industry if you've got the quality
of the production of film released
through social media and it's much more
likely to resonate with the people that
it's aimed at
to keep up its resistance against russia
the ukrainian government has also been
galvanizing domestic morale so it's been
turning some incidents into propaganda
opportunities for instance releasing
stamps showing the sinking of a russian
warship it's a very clear uh
illustration of a nation's kind of
authority really so what he's saying to
the people is we are still in control
we're beating the russians one way to
show that ukraine is putting up a fight
against russians is to display their
destroyed military vehicles in public
or at a museum where visitors can take a
closer look at war paraphernalia like
uniforms worn by russian soldiers
the ukrainian government told the wall
street journal it will continue to seize
every opportunity and use creative
methods to keep the world talking about
the war as long as it rages on
ukraine as well as russia have not
slowed down their push for support at
home and abroad the difference is that
ukraine has the support of the west and
russia doesn't therefore
russia is
only really able to use its propaganda
on its own people
and unlike much of the world many of
those inside russia remain out of reach
for ukraine's ongoing pr campaign
[Music]